practiquemos un poco más con el sistema
rs aquí tenemos un compuesto y este
carbono es un centro que irá pero voy a
dibujarlo para que sea más fácil asignar
la configuración aquí tenemos el carbono
después tenemos un grupo metilo hacia
nosotros vamos a dibujar
después tenemos un hidrógeno lejos de
nosotros y hacia la derecha tenemos un
ch 2 que forma parte del anillo aquí
tenemos un carbono con dos hidrógenos
después tenemos un ch este carbono unido
a un hidrógeno sería este carbono del
anillo y observen que este carbono está
unido con un doble enlace a este carbono
para el sistema r o ese paso porque este
carbono está unido a dos carbonos aunque
en realidad sabemos que sólo es uno así
es como podemos manejar un doble enlace
ahora de este lado del anillo tenemos un
ch 2 vamos a dibujar
ch2 después tenemos otro se h 2c h 2 y
después este carbono está unido a este
carbono dibujemos una línea
ok ahora asignemos las prioridades este
es el centro kieran analicemos los
cuatro grupos unidos al centro gira que
es el paso 1
hay que priorizar los cuatro grupos
usando el número atómico entonces que
está unido directamente a este carbono
bueno tenemos un hidrógeno un carbono
otro carbono y otro carbono en términos
de número atómico el carbono le gana al
hidrógeno así que el hidrógeno es el
grupo de menor prioridad vamos a
asignarle el número 4 y después tenemos
3 carbonos pero podemos analizar a que
están unidos
esos carbonos empecemos con el carbono
de arriba este carbono está unido a un
hidrógeno hidrógeno e hidrógeno vamos a
escribir hidrógeno hidrógeno hidrógeno
ahora vamos con el carbono de la derecha
este carbono está unido a un carbono
hidrógeno y un hidrógeno carbono
hidrógeno hidrógeno puse el carbono
primero porque los ordenamos según la
disminución del número atómico ahora
este carbono está unido a un carbono un
hidrógeno y otro hidrógeno entonces se h
h hagamos la comparación aquí tenemos un
hidrógeno y acá un carbono el carbono
gana y también por acá tenemos un
carbono así que este grupo el grupo
metilo tiene la prioridad número 3 y
después tenemos hidrógeno hidrógeno pero
por acá también tenemos hidrógeno e
hidrógeno así que necesitamos analizar
el siguiente átomo para saber quién gana
si nos movemos al siguiente carbono este
carbono está unido a un carbono carbono
e hidrógeno
entonces carbono carbono hidrógeno
mientras que este carbono está unido
directamente a un carbono hidrógeno e
hidrógeno
entonces carbono hidrógeno hidrógeno
vamos a ver aquí tenemos carbono y
carbono pero después tenemos carbono
hidrógeno y como el carbono gana eso
significa que esta parte del anillo
tiene una prioridad más alta así que
este lado es el número 1 y este lado del
anillo es el número dos ya que asignamos
las prioridades
vamos con el paso 2 hay que orientar los
grupos para que el grupo de menor
prioridad quede hacia atrás regresemos a
la estructura original ya dijimos que
este lado del anillo es el número 1 este
lado es el número 2
el grupo metilo es el número 3 y el
hidrógeno es el número 4 y miren el
grupo de menor prioridad ya se encuentra
lejos de nosotros porque el hidrógeno
está representado con esta línea
punteada ya
se encuentra hacia atrás finalmente en
el paso 3 hay que determinar si la
secuencia 1-2-3 es en el sentido de las
manecillas del reloj o en contrarreloj
vamos a ver si dibujamos un círculo que
pase por 1 2 y 3
miren nos movemos en esta dirección que
es como la de las manecillas del reloj
así que la configuración es r la
configuración de este centro quiral es r
ahora veamos este compuesto aquí tenemos
el centro girar pero analicemos los
átomos que están unidos directamente a
este centro gira observen que tenemos un
bromo un cloro por acá tenemos un
carbono y por acá tenemos otro carbono
recuerden la prioridad se asigna según
el número atómico en este caso de todos
estos átomos el bromo tiene el número
atómico más alto así que el bromo es el
número uno después está el cloro con un
número atómico de 17 es el número 2 y
después tenemos 2 carbonos pero
analicemos a que están unidos
bueno el carbono de la derecha está
unido a un carbono un carbono y un
hidrógeno vamos a escribir carbono
carbono hidrógeno mientras que el
carbono de la izquierda está unido a un
carbono y dos hidrógenos tenemos carbono
hidrógeno hidro
vamos a ver aquí tenemos un carbono y un
carbono pero después tenemos carbono
hidrógeno el carbono gana así que este
grupo tiene mayor prioridad el grupo
hizo pro pilot es el número 3 y el grupo
etilo es el número 4 ok ahora que ya
asignamos prioridades necesitamos
orientar la molécula para que el grupo
de menor prioridad se encuentre hacia
atrás es decir el grupo número 4 a
continuación les mostraré un vídeo en el
que veremos dos formas en las que
podemos poner este grupo hacia atrás una
forma es imaginar que un eje pasa por
este carbón y así rotamos la molécula
hasta que el grupo de menor prioridad
quede lejos de nosotros pero otra forma
sería como en la proyección de newman
porque si observamos este enlace desde
aquí estaríamos viendo el grupo de menor
prioridad el grupo de tilos
lejos de nosotros esa sería la otra
forma
este es nuestro compuesto la esfera roja
es el bromo y la amarilla es el cloro
nuestro objetivo es rotar la molécula
para que el grupo de menor prioridad
quede atrás imaginemos que un eje pasa
por el centro gira y lo rotamos para que
el grupo de tilo quede hacia atrás ahora
el bromo está a la izquierda el cloro
hacia la derecha y el grupo isopropílico
hacia arriba si regresamos al principio
ahora observemos este enlace carbono
carbono rotemos la molécula esta es una
perspectiva diferente pero aún podemos
ver el bromo hacia la izquierda
el cloro hacia la derecha y el grupo
isopropílico hacia arriba
esto es lo que vemos al observar el
enlace carbono carbón este carbono es el
centro kirk al que corresponde a este
después tenemos el bromo de color rojo y
el cloro de color amarillo observen que
el bromo se encuentra hacia la izquierda
y es el grupo de mayor prioridad el
cloro que se encuentra hacia la derecha
es el número 2 después tenemos el grupo
isopropílico hacia arriba que es el
número 3 y el grupo de menor prioridad
se encuentra hacia atrás así que
únicamente necesitamos dibujar un
círculo que pase por 1 2 y 3
miren nos movemos en esta dirección es
decir encontrar el ojo así que la
configuración de este centro quiral es
ese